food establishments casinos and hotels
are some of the top spots local health
officials
claim are helping the spread of covid19
now we first brought you that
information
part of the data that was recently
uncovered by our eye team and continues
to have many
raised eyebrows around the valley
christian casares joining us live from
the newsroom with some concerns from
local residents who are receiving this
information
christian well brian we spoke to several
residents about this information and
many were not surprised food
establishments hotels
and medical facilities running off the
top spot for
a new list from the southern nevada
health district take a look there on
your screen you will see the chart
now since the start of the pandemic the
southern nevada health district
reported more than 23 800 cases
in the state in the last 30 days more
than 3
300 cases all of them listed other as
their source
which which with the health district
basically tells us that they're working
on to better define that they say
that it can be anything from an
individual's home national
park or even a playground now we talked
to some more local residents today and
they tell us
outdoor activities was their way to go
trips to the dog park or hiking
were among their top favorites to avoid
any indoor gatherings
which they say could be risky get used
to it
you know i'd like i like to go out you
know
especially for dinners and things like
it with my wife and
but we've since all this came about we
kind of pretty much stay home
like i said i come to the park every day
just to bring him in so i can walk
but yeah it's not much i can do
there is no known virus transmission
from hair or nail salons now more than
two hundred and sixteen thousand cove
nineteen cases have been reported right
here in clark county according
to the health district since january
twenty twenty now
more than thirty three hundred people
have died from the virus right here in
clark county as well
now rounding out the list are grocery
stores casinos and air travel that
showed
the least amount of positive cases all
that information was collected through
contract tracing according to health
officials information that as
you can imagine is still being processed
every single day brian and again these
are locations where people
think they got the virus the term other
is listed very vague of course
and a bit concerning do we know anything
more about what other could mean in
terms of the report christian
well bryan health officials said that
they are still working to dissect this
category which like we mentioned
includes
homes parks etc but many residents we
talked to today said
that they believe house gatherings is
the most concerning for them
one woman even telling us today that her
senior citizen complex
has constant gatherings among residents
which health officials say
is highly discouraged christian casadas
8 news now all right christian thank you
for that report